good morning for those of you have not
had the chance to meet my name is George
Joseph and I'm the deputy director of
the the Whitney and Betty McMillan
Center for International and area
studies at Yale and the center along
with its program on refugees forced
displacement and humanitarian responses
is the conveners of today's symposium so
I'm not going to speak to you about the
content of today's symposium you know
all of that much more than I do what I
simply want to do in a very brief two or
three minutes is just to say a little
bit about why it is that McMillan
decided to undertake this program
beginning really over the course of the
last year and and I frankly regard the
spring semester the term that we have
just wrapping up there's really a soft
launch for the program over the over the
course of this last term the the program
in the center along with a series of
partners across the university have
convened about a dozen odd events and
speakers films and we plan to do much
more over the over the remaining weeks
of the term but then we'll also see much
more activity in the next academic year
so this really was just a start of
something that has there really begins
to crystallize a set of discussions that
have been happening across campus for
really over the last year so let me say
a little bit about what McMillan does
and how it relates back to this
particular program those of you who have
been at Yale or those of you been in
academia in particular for know that
universities by their nature tend to be
silos
they tend to be institutions where you
comment things from a particular
geography from a particular discipline
perhaps from a particular geography from
a particular methodology and there are
very few spaces where individuals and
scholars and practitioners from a
variety of different perspectives can
come together and share up that they are
their interests and that has really been
what McMillan has tried to do over over
its long history in the case of the
program on refugees of which this is the
first convening symposium is that we
with over the course of discussions we
found that there are faculty across Yale
in the medical school in the nursing
school in Public Health in the Divinity
School in the School of Management in
the Law School as well as the the
Faculty of Arts and Sciences who are all
interested in essentially is the
umbrella theme of refugees and a broader
issue of displacement but because of the
way that Yale and because of the way
that institutions like Yale are
organized it's very challenging for them
to come together some of this is
disciplinary there are anthropologists
and economists and there are physicians
and there are public health individuals
are looking at it from different
perspectives somewhat of his geography
in the case of Yale are nursing schools
on the west campus are public health and
medical schools and the hospital is on
medical campus and then we have the the
arts and sciences and other professional
schools on the North Campus and so there
are not the kinds of opportunities that
we would like - to bring people together
and all of these were motivations for
what what really prompted us to think
about how you make melon as a
university-wide center can serve that
convening role so what is it that we
hope to do apart from bringing people
together and that's going to be a very
key piece of what we will do it is our
goal and our hope is not to subsume or
take on what others are already doing
rather we want to really be a platform
to share this work across a wider
spectrum of individuals across Yale but
also the New Haven Connecticut
communities and in fact there are those
of you who are not necessarily in the
Yale academic community but are
representing organizations working on
these issues from across Connecticut
over the next over the coming really the
next weeks and months one of the things
that we will be doing is launching a
series of research programs as well as
providing more opportunities for
students and we'll also call on you to
help us in terms of convening
programming next year what McMillan does
apart from convening is that it tries to
bring resources to the table that
whether it's in terms of supporting
research whether it's convenient ents
but the goal essentially is that we
really want to use the resources that we
have both intellectual as well as
financial two to really to be able to
airhead some of these efforts that
otherwise might not find a foothold at
Yale
so the addendum is broadest terms are is
what we are hoping to do over the next
coming weeks and months but one of the
first things that we wanted to do is and
this is the reason that we're meeting
today is to have an opportunity for
individuals from across CL as well as
New Haven in Connecticut to come
together to be able to to begin to share
and begin to first actually frankly just
meet each other because there are not as
many opportunities for that at New Haven
or any ideal either so that is really
the goal today we as the program was
built out we had arranged for a lot of
downtime in terms of breaks and a long
lunch as well as a networking reception
at the end of the day we've tried to
involve faculty scholars practitioners
students again a range of different
people from across yell and youhave and
who we thought would be interested and
again our ambition and our hope is that
this particular conference or this
particular symposium is really an
in-house event but in subsequent years
our hope is that it will grow to
something more something more fulsome
that involves a lot of others from
across across these disciplines and not
necessarily a year later so before I
step away from the podium and introduce
our first speaker I want to just point
out a couple things the first is you
will have the program which lays out the
the agenda for the day and the and a
loop and I should would not be I would
be doing a great disservice if I did not
acknowledge a few people who over the
course of the semester have really tried
to bring all this together so as all of
you know and you probably have the first
person that who I think all of you have
encountered in some form is hanan al
Dudley who's sitting right in the very
front and
[Applause]
I don't I not give making it an
understatement in saying that this would
not have been the way the program is
developed even in its form over the last
several weeks and months would not have
been possible without announced efforts
we really wanted someone who could step
up and help to just convene people and
talk to people from across Gale and anon
has been able to do that we and they
think again we'll see much more but we
need to start with by thanking on for
all of our efforts the others who I need
to acknowledge are not in the room but I
want to at least let you know that the
website and the communications and other
aspects of McMillan's work was put
together by Marilyn Wilks who is the
director for communications as well as
Lisa Brennan who is the webmaster and
web designer for the Macmillan Center
and apart from within Macmillan the
other people I need to mention are
they're there again how we've approached
the program is to draw in people from
across Gale and there are faculty and
centers and units at the law school at
the Jackson Institute at the Medical
School in public health nursing and a
number of other schools and faculties
across Yale that without their support
that's everything that we've done over
the last semester would not have been
possible so we're grateful to all of
them and finally we're grateful to all
of you those of you who are presenting
those of you who are listening and
contributing in your own ways and and
what I would encourage you to do and not
only today but over the coming days and
weeks
it just is continue to give us your
feedback about what more you would like
to see the program do and how you would
like to see it shaped as much as we are
the Macmillan Center is bringing is
serving this convening role we also
regard our work is very organic it is
not we don't have a template and a and a
road map already sketched out rather we
try to be responsive and we want to be
responsive to individual faculty as well
as the interest of others across the
campus so with that let me say thank you
and welcome and if you have any
questions about Macmillan or about the
program do not hesitate to reach out to
her nun or to myself and and we really
look forward to an exciting day of
discussions and presentations so with
that let me turn the the podium over to
Professor Kathryn Patrick a professor
birack is a professor of anthropology as
well as health and global affairs she
holds an appointment in the Jackson
Institute for Global Affairs as well as
the department's of anthropology and the
Macmillan Center and the Faculty of Arts
and Sciences she's a medical
anthropologist
trained both in human biology as well as
in the social sciences she in addition
to the work that she's been doing with
the program she also directs within
Macmillan Center the program on conflict
resilience and health as well as the
anthropologist program on stress and
family resilience the full profile for a
professor Patrick is in your material so
I'm not going to take any more time
other than to welcome her to the podium
to give her remarks thank you good
morning morning so it's my turn to have
the privilege of welcoming you today can
you hear me yes
so today in terms of opening comments to
open up the conversation in room I would
like us to reflect together on one
question that is important to me and
that question is how we can strive to be
all of us better humanitarians each of
us I think has something to offer
perhaps to offer to research or to
practice auto policy I think each of us
has something to offer to have as a
teacher as a student as an advocate have
a fundraiser as an administrator as an
artist even perhaps as a potential donor
by being present in this room each of us
is declared in interest and humanitarian
studies and in humanitarianism and
refugee studies so I think we're here to
reflect on the next generation of
humanitarian
those challenges that we face today and
the challenges that we are likely to
face in the future which echo those we
face in the past we reflect in order to
grasp how we made deepen our
understanding of challenging situations
and how we may seize on opportunities to
develop a more reflective effective and
relevant agenda for making it for doing
things to make a substantial difference
in the world today it's important to
know there's already been much
innovation in the field of refugee
studies moving forward I'd like us to
consider what we can do to be better
humanitarians as researchers
practitioners policymakers or activists
or teachers so I would like us to use
today as an opportunity to make a
difference in our understanding of
humanitarian values and humanitarianism
is encompasses the field of research in
the field of practice and those two
dimensions research and practice are
under twined in a context of exceptional
suffering violence chaos orphan failure
and discrimination humanitarians are
those who save lives and alleviate
suffering and support recovery but I
think that humanitarians are also those
who think deeply about questions of our
issues of sufferings vulnerability and
dignity and surely that includes us in
this room humanitarianism emphasizes I
think a moral dimension of a shared
humanity a practice of compassion that
extends to all human beings and
historically this humanity Essex has
been including for instance in Europe in
18th and 19th century social reforms
that prohibited the use of torture
cruelty to children the abolition of
slavery inhumane treatment of the
mentally ill reforms that fostered
participations justice for women and
other disenfranchised groups so I think
my point here is that this ethic of a
shared humanity has articulated in a
cascade of human rights and social with
reforms have propelled change is driven
change in the field of law health and
politics in the past and I think with
poet poised today to have to witness
more efforts to drive and usher in
another wave of social ethical political
legal health reforms to address a broken
refugee system which is the phrase that
Alex Delaney cough former UN deputy High
Commissioner for Refugees used in his
talk last year a broken refugee system
far forward to international
humanitarian action in 2017 we have had
strong calls made for robust
humanitarian responses to address
comprehensively the needs of refugees
and the concerns of states who yield
power over the lives and the livelihoods
we have had many academic papers that
have been written on the future of
refugee studies but because this is a
very fast changing field we need to take
a moment to reflect carefully on our
agenda so today I think is about our
capacities for critical reflection and
determination being a better
humanitarian means that we work to
define our expectations of what is the
right thing to do in situations of
suffering and injustice you'll see in
today's program session addressing legal
issues the challenges of current
humanitarian systems the rebuilding of
health systems the everyday lives of
refugees and specific examples of
humanitarian actions I hope we're going
to hear today more about research
priorities about partnerships
innovations and accountability because I
personally remember writing in 2015 the
introduction to an edited book or
medical
and sitting in my kitchen and writing
that a plea to inspire innovation
accountability and relevance in this
field and I love those words innovation
accountability and relevance because I
love those words I'm very interested in
them such showcase examples of
innovative humanitarian practice effort
to better communicate the lived
experience of refugees and address
issues of suffering and dignities ways
to forge new approaches to partnerships
between research institutions and
humanitarian organizations ways to share
relevant information and practices so
today I would think is about building a
foundation for grounded mindful and
constructive dialogue between science
research science social science and
humanitarian practice for me being a
humanitarians is to focus on the dignity
of the lack of lives and the robustness
of legal health and political systems
being a humanitarian to hold an ethic of
compassion and care it's also to insist
on accountability in what we do and how
we implement that duty of care as
humanitarian researchers teachers and
activists we need to hold ourselves
accountable to producing or for
producing truthful representations of
people's lives and for creating better
ways of serving them so I think we're
here today to learn from each other to
innovate to build better evidence I hope
we put in place the next generation of
data gathering work partnership building
forward-thinking policy and teachable
insights for humanitarian practice and I
thank the Macmillan Center for being a
catalyst in getting us together
for this symposium today thank you
[Applause]
[Music]